Qué son las fuerzas de apoyo rápido y de
dónde derivan estas tensiones actuales
con los militares de Sudán bien el
origen se remonta al régimen de Omar al
Valley puesto presidente de Sudán que
gobernó durante más de 30 años las
fuerzas de despegue rápido eran un grupo
especial dentro de la estructura del
ejército que dependía estrictamente al
vacío con las cuales fueron desplegadas
en lugares de alto nivel de conflicto
como dar puro Nilo azul ante la salida
de Omar al Valle desde que las fuerzas
de despliegue rápido se encuentran
acéfalas y aunque dependen del ejército
tienen un control y una capacidad propia
ante el golpe militar las diferencias
entre esta fuerza de despegue rápido y
el ejército que ilegítimamente se
encuentra en control del del Estado han
hecho que estos cruces de políticos de
distintos intereses
deriven en un enfrentamiento y ahora
vemos la parte más dura de ese
enfrentamiento político y para conocer
un poco De dónde viene Sudán no hablamos
del golpe de estado no cuando los
militares tomaron el poder en 2021 nos
daría un panorama De dónde viene Sudán
que estaba ocurriendo en ese momento por
qué se llegó ese golpe
Generalmente cuando te revisa la
situación hay una gran pérdida de
legitimidad del régimen conseguiremos
comer al valle de estado en el poder
desde 1986 con muchos años de gobierno
autocrático cuestiones como la inflación
la falta de trabajo en la cleptocracia
del estado y principalmente la falta de
capacidad de la sociedad civil de poder
acceder algo que en otros momentos
históricos de sudancia habían podido
lograr llevó a una declive de la
capacidad del régimen y cuando la gente
salió a derrotador derrocar o a criticar
Omar al Bayer el ejército rápidamente
que dependía de este líder tomó las
cartas en el asunto se adelantó el
movimiento civil y consolidó lo que fue
el golpe de estado El problema es que
desde ahí en adelante la lucha radica
entre la necesidad de generar una
transición de un gobierno autocrático a
un gobierno civil a un proceso de
transición que no termina donde los
militares han tratado de controlar todo
ese proceso Y tratar de desplegar o a
los civiles del Poder
y eventualmente esto genera un grave
problema tenemos tres grandes actores
civiles militares y ahora dentro de la
cúpula militar la lucha entre ellos y
las fuerzas de este rápido Ricardo como
decíamos al inicio del informativo de
los paramilitares aseguran que controlan
sitios clave no hablábamos del
Aeropuerto Internacional de la capital
el Palacio presidencial además de
algunas bases militares de ser así que
escenarios se abren en este conflicto
Hacia dónde podría derivar
un punto de vista discursivo se ve que
las fuerzas de despegue rápido han
tratado de demostrar que tendrían
capacidad de tomar el poder el ejército
desde el punto de vista también de los
medios trata de demostrar de que se
encuentran bajo control la realidad es
que quizás lo que más demuestra esta
situación es que el gobierno del
gobierno de transición día directamente
monopolizado por los militares carece de
cualquier tipo de legitimidad o
institucionalidad suficiente dado que
ante la capacidad de resolver sus
conflictos internos derivamos en esta
escalada de violencia
nos queda Una última pregunta nos queda
poco tiempo pero no quiero dejar de
realizarse la varios Países Árabes
mostraron su preocupación por supuesto
ante esta situación la liga árabe de
hecho ofreció intervenir como mediadora
Según reportan varias fuentes esta
podría ser una vía de salida al
conflicto
la comunidad internacional tiene un
papel al presionar y y llevaron
una transición O sea que sea pacífica o
por lo menos eficiente consideremos que
ciudadanos de los pocos estados en todas
las grandes la gran región de cuerno de
África que
estarían dando una escalada de
inestabilidad sí descontamos la guerra
de Etiopía y
sumamos a Egipto sería el único estado
más o menos viable para para toda la
región la caída de sudando le
interesaría a la comunidad internacional
pero claramente hay que tratar de
resolver restos diferentes entre estos
grupos y en lo posible de la comunidad
internacional buscará que la transición
a un gobierno civil sea lo más pronto y
eficientemente posible